excusez pas seulement le goût de le faire mes
scripts d'école très solidement vous savez j'aimerai juste
parler fort et dépendre des gens d'
accord
bienvenue à cette discussion merci d'être venu
donc c'est organisé par 50 votes sagesse
Lausanne nous en reparlerons plus
tard et  c'est pour le lancement du livre
que j'ai oublié d'apporter qui est un très
bon vendeur mais le livre que nous avons
écrit dans les médias et moi sur l'
effort de Fabri comment
officialiser l'IA sorbitol va rapidement au présentateur MIDI
il veut juste dire son doctorat sur l'apprentissage  le
postdoc au MIT il a aussi écrit un premier
livre intitulé l'équation des connaissances sur la
biologie et c'est avec plaisir que je
contribue à ce projet avec lui cette
fois donc on travaille sur la sécurité de l'IA cette
phrase quand on dit ça amis famille
gens dans les gens dans  les transports en
commun c'est c'est une
réaction typique que nous obtenons oh tu es oh
tu t'inquiètes pour un avenir lointain
c'est important avec ça c'est toujours des
préoccupations à long terme et les gens
pensent que nous nous en soucions  comme alors les gens quand ils
entendent que c'est notre préoccupation est la propre
sécurité de l'IA, ils imaginent généralement que nous nous
soucions de quelque chose comme eux plus tard ou de
Skynet, en fait, ce qui nous importe est
quelque chose qui ressemble plus à ce problème
qu'à ce problème, donc ce que nous allons essayer de
transmettre  dans cet exposé, la première partie de
cet exposé porte sur l'urgence lorsque nous
disons que nous devrions travailler sur la sécurité de l'IA sur l'
éthique et l'éthique, nous ne parlons pas d'
un avenir à long terme farfelu ou spéculatif,
nous parlons de la
décision des plats  -faire des algorithmes de prise de décision
donc des outils qui traitent l'
information et prennent des décisions et
recommandent quotidiennement du contenu sur le cancer à des milliards d'
utilisateurs et qui peuvent avoir des
conséquences telles que le carburant dans la
propagande anti-vaccin ou le
déni du changement climatique ISM ou le discours de haine donc ceci
est ce dont nous nous soucions et quand nous disons hein
j'ai déjà dit comme ne pensez pas à
l'être conscient super intelligent
pensez à un traitement de l'information pour
donc un algorithme qui traite
je  L'information prend des entrées et produit
des sorties qui sont aussi des informations,
donc tout ce qui traite l'information
et aussi les préoccupations que nous soulèverons
dans cette conférence apparaissent principalement avec des
yeux modernes qui sont basés sur des données qui ont
appris à partir de données et ne sont pas entièrement
programmées à la main et  peut être audité à la
main par des programmeurs, donc quand nous disons IA
selon ce que je viens de mentionner, ce
n'est pas ce que nous entendons par IA à partir d'aujourd'hui à partir
d'aujourd'hui si vous voyez un robot dans une
exposition commerciale, il n'y a probablement
pas beaucoup d'IA  mais nous entendons
quelque chose comme
le système de recommandation YouTube, donc pour
ceux qui ne sont pas conscients de l'ampleur
de ce type d'IA basique mais toujours très
puissante aujourd'hui, il y aurait
plus de vues sur YouTube que de recherches sur
Google en une minute il y a  environ 4,6
millions de vues ou plus sur YouTube et
seulement 4,3 ou 3,4 désolé 3,3 point
quelque chose un million de recherches sur Google et
donc c'est quelque chose qui traite l'
information qui influence la décision  s
les choix des gens au quotidien à grande échelle
selon ce chef de produit
de YouTube le PDG de YouTube dans une
récente interview 70% de ces
vues sont recommandées par l'algorithme
donc nos sont faites parce que l'algorithme a
décidé que la personne regarderait ceci et
cela  et non et pas de recherche active, il
pourrait donc rechercher la dernière nouvelle utilisation de l'EPFL ou la
dernière science pour tous, comme par exemple la science
pour toutes les vidéos de théorie des jeux, puis
vous regarderez ceci, mais pour chaque vidéo que vous
regardez activement, vous en regarderez probablement
trois passivement pour ainsi dire  parce que l'
algorithme a pris la décision, c'est donc
ce qui nous importe dans les algorithmes de prise de décision
qui traitent les données et ont un
effet d'échelle, donc juste quelques questions pour
voir si vous avez compris, donc à partir d'aujourd'hui,
c'est cette IA si vous voyez quelque chose comme
ça dans  un supermarché ouais c'est
probablement qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup d'IA dedans d'accord
question facile oui
qu'en est-il de celui-ci alors oui vous en
avez Andrew avec le visage comme
Sofia encore une fois ouais
pas d'IA  excellence donc c'est c'est
selon ce que nous avons dit non pas parce
qu'il y a ces robots stupides mais parce
qu'il y a un logo Netflix et que Netflix a
un algorithme très puissant cela traite les
informations regardez-nous votre comportement et
essaie de recommander du contenu ou de vous garder
engagé avec  la plate-forme donc c'est ce sur
quoi nous allons beaucoup nous concentrer dans
cette conférence et par cela nous essayons de transmettre
l'urgence les gars déjà déjà déployés
ils peuvent être très stupides ils peuvent être
stupides ils ne sont pas conscients mais ils
sont puissants ok donc  oui, c'est le genre
de décisions qu'ils prennent, ils essaieront de
prédire si vous avez cliqué sur cette
vidéo de lei ou si vous ne cliquez pas et ne cliquez pas
sur celle-ci qui est des
mathématiques très hardcore ou non si ou
combien regarderiez-vous  restez
jusqu'à la fin de cette vidéo ou partiriez-
vous après avoir regardé quelques secondes
, puis et puis quitter la
plate-forme et leur objectif est d'essayer de
vous engager et de vous garder engagé
avec th  e contenus et bien sûr prédire
prédire quels contenus vont vous engager
et pour ce faire ils ne sont pas programmés à la
main car il y a plein de choses
à regarder comment faites vous défiler votre souris qui
sont vos amis etc donc si vous en avez fait
un peu  de l'informatique que vous connaissez sur la
programmation la programmation est l'écriture d'
instructions d'écriture de code si cela est autre,
traitez cela si vous voyez que a est
différent de B suggérez ceci, etc. afin que vous
puissiez considérer un programme comme un très très
grand ensemble de tuners que vous voulez
veux vous trouver et dans les années 1950 en 93
- vous
avez raison  comportement
nous nous retrouverions avec des milliards de boutons
et si vous voulez écrire cela à la main
c'est une échelle et très tôt il s'est
rendu compte que la voie à suivre est d'apprendre quels
sont les bons paramètres qui correspondent à l'entrée
sortie par exemple la prédiction vidéo de
ce que wh  ether vous resteriez ou pas pour
que je prédis quel genre de vidéo
vous ferait rester ou quel genre de
produit vous ferait commander etc donc
et pour le faire très très très vite on
regarde les paires d'entrées et de sorties qu'on
a on  calculons l'erreur commise par notre
réglage et nous essayons de minimiser l'erreur
afin de prédire la sortie dans laquelle nous prédisons
la correspondance d'une meilleure manière à l'
avenir et cela se fait avec un
algorithme appelé descente de gradient donc
c'est juste optimisation optimisation
optimisation  les paramètres afin que nous puissions
prédire la sortie compte tenu de l'entrée en
minimisant une erreur et en
minimisant cette erreur se
joignaient presque à un autre cadre d'
apprentissage automatique est ce que nous appelons l'
apprentissage par renforcement, c'est-à-dire laissons simplement
l'algorithme faire des actions aléatoires les
paramètres  qui font un comportement correct
sont renforcés ou conservés les paramètres
le mauvais comportement ne sont pas encore ne sont pas
renforcés donc nous essayons de maximiser un
résumé donc nous essayons d'aimer avoir un  récompenser
que le train oblige à bien se comporter ce
framework s'appelle
apprentissage par renforcement et au
bout de ce framework il y a il y a
une notion importante de récompense qui n'est
pas très loin donc c'est du très haut niveau
ce n'est pas une introduction technique mais
ce n'est pas ça  très loin cette récompense
cette carotte n'est pas très loin de l'
erreur que vous voulez minimiser dans le
paramètre d'aperçu vous avez des entrées sorties
vous voulez minimiser l'erreur ici vous
avez des comportements et vous voulez maximiser
les récompenses donc vous voulez faire les
comportements  qui maximisent la récompense d'accord
pour ceux qui n'ont pas fait d'informatique
pensez à un enfant apprenant une langue l'
enfant n'est pas programmé avec des
instructions de langue qu'il
irait probablement voir une dame et dirait bonjour
oncle et ensuite la dame disait je suis  pas
votre oncle donc c'est une récompense négative
et alors peut-être que s'ils disent salut la tante est
heureuse donnez à l'enfant un bonbon l'
enfant renforcera le match face à la
femme pour dire en tante et match
face à un homme ne devrait pas le dire d'abord à
dire chez une femme pour ne pas dire oncle
donc il y a quelque chose à programmer pour
programmer des algorithmes nous utilisons cela nous utilisons
cette analogie et il est important de
comprendre qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
différence lorsque nous prenons  lorsque nous parlons
de sécurité, la seule chose que vous devez
garder à l'esprit qu'il y a un
objectif d'accord minimiser l'erreur maximiser la
récompense maximiser le temps d'engagement
maximiser le nombre de produits
commandés sur Amazon, etc. d'accord donc il y a
un objectif et pour que cela devrait
être atteint alors maximiser quelque chose et
ensuite nous pourrions avoir une
conversation donc c'est un bon moyen d'
avoir des machines intelligentes ou des
algorithmes intelligents nous n'avons pas besoin de les programmer à la
main mais que leur donnons-nous comme
métrique comme objectif a  le profit semble
être une chose raisonnable à maximiser si vous
voulez survivre en tant qu'entreprise, il est très
juste qu'il soit tout à fait raisonnable d'essayer
de maximiser votre profit ou du moins de
maximiser le profit avec  n la loi d'accord
dans ce qui est acceptable et légal dans
le pays ou fonctionne donc il n'y a
rien a priori qui ne soit pas
mais en maximisant le profit ou comme Lee aime
à dire si vous demandez aux gens il y a 10 ans en
utilisant des plates-formes de base voulez-vous
voulez-vous  pour être recommandé du contenu
qui vous intéresse, ils
diront probablement oui je ne veux pas avoir de
contenu qui ne correspond pas à mes intérêts, donc
si nous essayons d'avoir un proxy comme les clics ou
regarder comme objectif, il semble donc que ce soit
semble a priori raisonnable de faire pour
rendre l'algorithme pertinent donc en
fin de compte quelque chose comme YouTube
comme il y a 10 ans on m'a demandé si vous
voulez travailler sur notre algorithme qui
veut juste divertir les gens je dirais
probablement oui ça sonne pas  seul groupe
mais même comme bénéfique comme moi
proposant aux gens de donner aux gens ce
qu'ils veulent après tout et vous pouvez alors demander
ce qui peut mal tourner alors peut-être que vous voulez
faire le clic alors qu'est-ce qui peut ressembler à un angle
ce qui est si mauvais de faire ce genre o  f
maximisation et il s'avère que
cela a de mauvaises implications et je
pense que ce n'est pas l'objectif de
YouTube, comme divertir les gens ne
semble pas si mal, mais le gros problème, ce sont les
effets secondaires maintenant, chaque fois que vous avez une
entité influente, cela peut  être une entreprise
peut être une agence d'art peut être un humain
chaque fois que vous avez quelque chose qui est
déployé à grande échelle,
tout ce qu'il optimise pour cela
aura des effets secondaires, car
chaque fois que vous interagissez avec des
milliards de personnes en même temps,
il y aura  il y a des synergies étranges
et des choses que vous ne pouvez pas
prédire facilement maintenant de cette façon, vous pouvez
prendre l'exemple du grand faucon qui
a vu ça le grand câlin c'est un
documentaire sur Netflix je le recommande
c'est très intéressant
donc c'est à propos du kimbridge
scandale analytique Facebook,
donc comme la brève histoire, l'histoire même de la
naissance est qu'il y avait essentiellement cette
société appelée achèvement Attica, elle
récupère les données des utilisateurs sur  Facebook et l'
utilisation qui utilise ces données pour faire des
campagnes politiques ciblées, en particulier lors de
l'élection présidentielle aux États-Unis,
et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que tout au long de
ce film, vous sentez que les
journalistes soutiennent qu'il se passe
quelque chose de mal, mais ce n'est pas très
clair quoi  est si mauvais à propos de ce qui se
passait comme nous effaçons cette impression,
mais sans doute pas différentes raisons pour lesquelles
nous trouvons quelque chose de mal à propos de ce qui
s'est passé, l'une des raisons est que la
confidentialité est la confidentialité comme la confidentialité
des données comme beaucoup de gens ont fait valoir que
tandis que les gens  a consenti a dit oui au
partage des données sur Facebook, ils ne se sont pas
rendus compte qu'ils disaient oui
parce que nous recevons cette notification tout le
temps et ils nous demandent un accord
pour partager certaines sortes de choses et la plupart
d'entre nous m'ont en fait embrassé mais la plupart de  nous
ne lisons pas tous les détails, je ne
pense pas que quiconque comme essentiellement personne
ne le fasse et les détails étaient dans cet
accord, donc dans un sens, il n'y avait
vraiment rien  illégal donc il y a
comme une contagion comme il y a comme des
points discutables ici mais essentiellement
comme la façon dont les données ont été partagées
sans doute pas si illégales que le problème est
plus que les gens n'étaient pas
assez préoccupés par ces choses mais d'un
point de vue juridique c'est  pas clair ce qui
n'allait pas l'autre Harlem qui est
assez différent en fait du
premier c'est le fait que grâce à ces
outils on pouvait maintenant avoir un
ciblage massif des campagnes politiques
et c'est vraiment nouveau comme si on y
réfléchissait longtemps quand  nous donnions des
choses à grande échelle nous devions faire de l'
industrialisation nous devions faire de l'
uniformisation des évités que nous
prévoyions de vendre ou de propager comme
de diffuser comme un message mais grâce aux
intelligences artificielles vous pouvez maintenant faire du
ciblage vous pouvez vraiment cibler et
adapter  personnalisez votre message aux
différentes agences de public et cela a
été vraiment critiqué par les
documentaires, mais encore une fois, si vous y
réfléchissez, ce n'est pas si illégal  comme
après tout, comme faire de mauvaises
campagnes rituelles est considéré par beaucoup comme la
base de la démocratie, donc
ce qui n'allait pas encore une fois n'est pas très clair, il y a des
cas limites, mais même si ce n'était pas
si illégal, cependant, si vous avez regardé le
documentaire, vous sentez que quelque chose
ne va pas  même si ce n'est pas
nécessairement faux sur le plan juridique, il y a
quelque chose qui semble mal sur le plan éthique, mais
peut-être que la conclusion la plus importante
de ce documentaire peut-être encore
plus importante que la tendance que j'ai
mentionnée est le fait que tout cela n'était
pas du tout anticipé comme tout  cela
semble être une surprise pour la plupart des gens,
même pour les employés de Facebook Facebook et
que vraiment la partie difficile de la
chose difficile à faire, mais en
pensant à ces
intelligences artificielles ces yeux, c'est que c'est
quelque chose de très différent de ce qui était
autrefois est très difficile à anticiper  les
conséquences du déploiement de ces
hey eyes à des échelles très massives et
c'est quoi t'es le mome  Ce qu'il faut retenir, c'est que
nous devrions avoir ce genre de
documentaires et d'événements, c'est que ces choses se
produisent déjà et qu'elles se
produisent depuis pas mal d'années maintenant, mais
nous n'étions pas préparés et nous ne le sommes toujours
pas, nos sociétés ne sont pas
préparées à ce genre de choses.  des choses légalement,
nous n'avons rien qui soit adapté à
ce type de société et aussi comme
la façon dont nous pensons aux différents
problèmes n'est pas adaptée à la façon dont le
monde est réellement c'est très difficile c'est
très très difficile à faire pour prévoir
tout cela parce que
nous avons des cerveaux limités et que nous avons utilisé votre
environnement limité et aussi comme nous
avons cela très comme nous nous soucions, mais ce qui est
aujourd'hui, mais le problème avec l'IA, c'est
qu'ils progressent constamment, il y
a beaucoup de recherches en cours sur l'IA et
il y a  beaucoup de nouvelles percées
arrivent chaque année dans l'IA donc ce n'est pas
suffisant de penser à un regard d'
aujourd'hui c'est en fait important d'essayer de se
projeter dans le futur et
on se demande ce que peut  t ces domaines peuvent
être à l'avenir quel peut être l'impact et
comment devrions-nous nous adapter à un monde dont nous
ne savons pas grand-chose, donc c'est l'
une des choses qui est très difficile
maintenant de cette façon directement un autre
effet secondaire, je pense que le  mot effet secondaire est
vraiment critique ici comme encore une fois ce n'est pas
l'intention des yeux qui est
problématique, ce sont les effets secondaires que la
maximisation de cette fonction objective a
lorsque vous déployez ces zones à grande
échelle peut-être l'une des choses les plus effrayantes
, peut-être le graphique de greffe le plus effrayant
il y a peut-être celui-ci est un
graphique de l'augmentation alors que la
projection aux états-unis  vous avez ces
deux grands partis comme les démocrates et
les républicains et vous voyez qu'ouvertement
et de plus en plus polarisé
la démo les démocrates deviennent de plus
en plus démocrates sur tous les points et les
républicains deviennent de plus en plus
républicains sur tous les points  il y a des
choses qui sont peut-être même plus
inquiétantes que celles-ci comme le fait que
les démocrates et les républicains
ne se détestent plus ni ne se détestent comme chaque côté comme
la moitié de chaque côté voit voit l'autre
côté comme une menace pour l'avenir des États
-Unis c'est  très déroutant et inquiétant et
aussi c'est un grand soi-disant
écart de perception, ce qui signifie que les démocrates ont une
vision très très exagérée et biaisée
des républicains et vice-versa
et ce n'est pas vraiment bon pour les
primes de coordination et je suis juste comme
penser correctement à ces différents
problèmes pour l'avenir de l'humanité,
un autre effet secondaire inquiétant auquel il est
vraiment rigide est le premier de la
dépendance, donc si vous pensez à cela  est-
ce que c'est comme si c'était même un peu exagéré
d'appeler cela un effet secondaire, car après
tout, si nos cheveux attirent notre
attention, c'est souvent ce qu'ils
maximisent pour bien, vous devriez vous attendre à ce que la
dépendance soit le résultat naturel
de choses essayant de maximiser l'
attention de la dépendance maintenant je veux parler un
peu de l'attention parce que je pense que c'est
très très important si vous y réfléchissez de
plus en plus comme nous disons souvent que le
bras de puissance est j'entends souvent que le
problème avec le capitalisme  est-ce que les entreprises
maximisent pour de l'argent ou quelque chose
comme ça
s'avère que de plus en plus la
monnaie, en particulier pour les grandes
entreprises sur Internet, comme les
startups, tout le reste sur Internet,
la grande monnaie devient de plus
en plus l'attention plutôt que l'argent si
vous pensez  à propos de ces nombreuses startups, ce
qu'elles vont essayer de faire en premier, c'est d'
obtenir une grande part du marché, une part de marché énorme
qui
attire d'abord votre attention, puis elles pensent peut-être
abo  ut ayant un modèle commercial mais
parfois ils ne pensent même
pas au modèle commercial si vous pensez à
Instagram par exemple, ces gars-là
optimisaient vraiment l'attention avant
tout, donc la vraie monnaie là-bas la chose pour
laquelle a déjà optimisé et
beaucoup  les entreprises qui optimisent pour
l'attention ne sont pas les
seules comme tant de gens
essaient d'attirer l'attention, je parle
des politiciens par exemple, eh bien, tous
les mouvements politiques dans les
organisations de médecins généralistes essaient d'attirer l'
attention les organismes de bienfaisance veulent votre attention
pour vous  donner de l'argent à des organisations caritatives et les
médias veulent votre attention et
bien sûr les gars comme moi les youtubers je veux
votre attention nous voulons tous votre
attention et il y a une grande compétition
la grande compétition aujourd'hui consiste à
attirer l'attention et les gars le
font très bien et si vous  réfléchissez à
ce qu'il faut faire lorsque vous essayez de
maximiser l'attention, il s'avère que
créer de la
diction est vraiment très bon s
stratégie et donc si vous pensez à l'amadou par
exemple, l'activité de Tinder est
censée faire correspondre les gens, mais
le mot que je n'obtiendrai pas plus de
bénéfices et plus de part de marché est en
maximisant l'attention, ils veulent que les
gens utilisent encore et encore l'amadou donc
notre attention est une très grande année et elle a de
grandes conséquences ennuyeuses, il y a donc
eu une étude funston's J'ai montré que
c'était en 2004 la
durée d'attention médiane des personnes travaillant sur un
lieu de travail était de trois minutes, donc toutes les
trois minutes, les gens changent de tâche ils
pourraient  ne pas se concentrer plus sur la morphine ou pas maintenant
quelques minutes ce n'est pas beaucoup de temps comme
vous n'avez pas beaucoup vous ne pouvez pas faire beaucoup
en trois minutes mais c'était trois
minutes il s'avère que ces jours-ci cette
durée d'attention est descendue à 40
secondes  alors maintenant, la
durée d'attention médiane selon une étude ressemble plus à
40 secondes et une grande partie de l'interruption
de l'attention en fait la moitié de celle
-ci n'est pas réellement due aux notifications sur
le téléphone  e bien que ce soit certainement une
grande partie de cela, mais en fait la moitié du
temps, les gens s'interrompent
eux-mêmes
pourquoi parce que nous venons de nous y habituer
et c'est un gros problème parce que si vous
pensez aux gros problèmes auxquels l'humanité est confrontée un
changement climatique constant  de faire des s étaient
fondamentalement bénéfiques ce sont
des problèmes très très compliqués ils ne peuvent pas être
résolus en 40 secondes ils nécessitent
beaucoup beaucoup d'attention et malheureusement
ces AIS ne maximisent pas notre
capacité à nous concentrer en fait leur
maximisation a comme effet secondaire ou
incapacité  se concentrer et c'est très
inquiétant pour les grands défis auxquels
nous sommes confrontés maintenant un autre problème qui peut-être
soulevé est le problème de l'
information donc voici par exemple une
question
qui a été posée par un gars nommé Hans
Rosling donc la question est de savoir comment le
nombre de  décès donc au nombre total ni à
la fraction le nombre total de décès
par an dus à des catastrophes naturelles a changé
au cours du siècle dernier a-t-il plus que
doublé a-t-il  il est resté plus ou moins le
même ou a-t-il diminué de moins de la moitié,
alors qui pense que c'est une réponse hey BC
pensez-vous que les gens ont répondu alors oui donc d'où la
première chose que ce peuple suédois
s'est avéré que les Suédois ne sont pas très bons
à ça comme la moitié  d'entre eux pensaient répondre,
donc la bonne réponse est jusqu'à ce que vous voyiez
les seuls 12% d'entre eux maintenant, il a également posé
cette question à un public, alors Ted si
vous ne savez pas à ce sujet, je
suppose que vous connaissez la conférence TED
mais si  vous ne connaissez pas les gens
qui sont revenus à ces conférences, donc
c'est une stabilité facile, pas TEDx,
la principale différence est que Ted est
beaucoup plus cher si vous voulez
y entrer, vous devez payer beaucoup d'
argent, vous devez donc  imaginez que le public
de Ted est comme quelles personnes bien informées
c'est très comme les plus informés et les
plus et aussi c'est un groupe de gens qui
se soucient vraiment de l'avenir de l'argent
ici quoi qu'il en soit et donc si vous êtes et donc
il a cette question devrait  le public
de Ted a  et comme vous pouvez le voir comme le
public de Ted
n'était vraiment pas si bon alors blague comme des
mains marchant comme des super adultes c'est
qu'ils ont fait pire que des chimpanzés auxquels
ils répondraient au hasard et et je pense que
cela montre vraiment que le premier de la
désinformation n'est pas un  problème pour
les gens très stupides comme nous avons tendance à penser
que d'une manière ou d'une autre, la qualité des informations
dont dispose quelqu'un est corrélée à son
intelligence ou à son succès et dans de
nombreux cas, c'est le cas, mais pour certaines
questions, ce n'est pas un cas d'abandon et
vous pouvez voir  voilà qu'en fait ici le
public de Ted est mal renseigné c'est pas
qu'il est ignorant c'est qu'il a tort
c'est plus tort que les chimpanzés dont on
me dit non avec l'actualité et ce n'est
pas propre au public de Ted a posé cette
question à  les médias par exemple et
au sein des médias il y a aussi une énorme
quantité d'erreurs sur des questions assez critiques
comme celle-ci semble être
que le genre de questions auxquelles vous auriez
besoin d'avoir une bonne réponse devrait
vous savez, quand vous dites que je connais
le monde, c'est le genre de questions dont
vous devriez probablement savoir quelque chose
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur le monde maintenant,
j'ai parlé de nombreux problèmes avec
les zones actuelles comme les zones actuelles ne
maximisent pas pour le  qualité de l'
information comme par exemple
il y a une étude qui a
montré que le climat les
vidéos pro changement climatique avaient à peu près le même
nombre de vues nous devrions prendre les
200 meilleures vidéos lorsque vous recherchez le
changement climatique sur YouTube vous avez essentiellement
le même nombre  de vues pour les pro-
changement climatique comme pour les climato-sceptiques donc 16
millions de vues de chaque côté en équilibre donc
clairement la qualité de l'information n'est
pas promue par ces AIS et
si vous vous souciez du changement climatique ou
peut-être que vous vous souciez de la justice sociale ou
moi comme  peu importe ce qui vous intéresse,
il s'avère que l'
information est essentielle et en particulier la
qualité de l'information est vraiment
essentielle, mais ce n'est pas ce que sont les yeux
promouvoir maintenant, j'ai parlé de
mauvaises choses à propos du mauvais côté des effets
secondaires d'un œil, mais il y a aussi des
opportunités et des opportunités qui
étaient probablement inimaginables avant l'
avènement d'un œil, le coin d'entre eux est
la possibilité de traiter une maladie mentale
ou  troubles mentaux donc aujourd'hui comme l'une
des pires choses en termes de bonheur dans
le monde est probablement toutes sortes de
dépression et de solitude même comme le
suicide et il est très difficile de les traiter
car il est très difficile d'obtenir des données
sur qui se sent seul qui est
déprimé  c'est une maladie très difficile à
guérir, mais il s'avère qu'en utilisant
ces AIS en utilisant les activités des gens
sur YouTube Facebook Twitter ou quoi que ce soit
ou Instagram, vous pouvez en déduire
beaucoup d'eux, donc ils avaient déjà
été étudiés une fois dans une phase sur Facebook
qui  a montré une corrélation entre la façon dont les
gens défilent sur leur téléphone lorsqu'ils utilisent
Facebook et la dépression signalée afin que vous
puissiez réellement faire des diagnostics à grande échelle  s en
utilisant ceci est si ces zones étaient
bénéfiques et c'est une énorme
opportunité non seulement vous pouvez faire un
diagnostic mais vous pouvez également faire un
traitement parce que beaucoup de ces maladies
toutes les informations auxquelles les gens sont
exposés et au lieu de promouvoir une autre
vidéo enragée  une autre vidéo en colère et une
autre vidéo déprimante ces zones
pourraient en fait suggérer des
vidéos thérapeutiques ou même des vidéos qui recommandent à l'
utilisateur d'aller voir un médecin et je pense
que c'est une énorme opportunité qu'il faut saisir car
il s'agit du bien-être
de centaines de
bâillements des gens maintenant peut-être que la plus grande
de mes
inquiétudes en revenant à lire les mots est le fait
que ces zones favorisent souvent la
colère et il y a une raison disponible à
cela est que la colère est extrêmement
addictive c'est aussi extrêmement engageant
il a été démontré que la chose que les
gens  partagera le plus facilement les
vidéos en colère les gens aiment être en colère et les
gens quand surtout quand les gens sont
déjà en colère comme quand  nous sommes en colère comme nous avons
tendance à vouloir être anguleux, nous
essayons d'expliquer pourquoi sur Greeners et
choisissons de montrer pourquoi la colère que
nous avons est justifiée et devrait être
promue et devrait être partagée et cela
a une énorme propagation de colère sur  les
médias sociaux qui ne sont vraiment vraiment pas bons
pour la capacité des gens à réfléchir
correctement à des problèmes difficiles et
compliqués et leur capacité à se
coordonner sur des défis importants maintenant
comment je vous montre qu'avec il y a
beaucoup de risques il y a beaucoup de très
mauvais côté  effets déjà mais il y a
aussi d'énormes possibilités d'utilisation de ceux-ci car vous
pourriez réduire ce genre d'énormes
mais vous êtes toujours capables de vous organiser
et il nous a fallu beaucoup de temps avant d'
inventer l'écriture l'écriture est le premier
média qui est externe à l'information
externaliser notre
traitement de la non-information  support d'informations je peux
écrire un message je peux le donner vous pouvez
revenir le lire vous pouvez le donner à
quelqu'un vous pouvez le copier et dès que
cette information est sortie  urce notre
voyage a vraiment décollé lorsque nous avons commencé à
externaliser les
informations de notre corps, il est donc important de
remonter aussi loin dans l'histoire pour
comprendre ce qui se passe ce à quoi nous sommes
confrontés alors encore une fois ce qu'il y a des millions d'années
aucune langue si humaine n'est il y a quelques milliers d'
années
non  d'accord,
nous pouvons partager des informations avec d'autres informations
[musicales]
, nous avons découvert des informations
traitant les informations de traitement, nous
pouvons programmer la machine pour le faire
, puis il y a quelques jours, nous avons réalisé que nous
pouvions automatiser la programmation du
traitement universel des informations,
donc si vous y réfléchissez  même des
organisations comme l'altruisme efficace
qui veulent faire du bien les Indiens qui
travaillent pour merci dans le RISM 250 volts ce
qu'ils font est un siècle de
traitement de données traitement de l'information
mon travail est le traitement de l'information je ne fais
que lire ces articles archivés et
je suis  faire des vidéos à partir d'eux, son travail est le
traitement de l'information comme s'il lisait
tout et écrivait des papiers, donc
beaucoup de t  hings est l'information et l'
information est essentielle si vous voulez
faire le bien, vous avez besoin d'une meilleure information à la
fois des données et d'un meilleur
traitement de l'information, donc vous connaissez tous notre high
quand il est arrivé à l'
EPFL, il a dit parfois ceux qui
contrôlent le flux de données  dans le
monde pour contrôler l'avenir non seulement de l'
humanité mais aussi peut-être de la vie elle
-même et donc je pense que c'est un très bon point
et cela soulève la question comme qui
contrôle aujourd'hui le flux de données
qui contrôle l'endroit où les données sont
collectées  et là où ça va bien, je
dirais que l'entité d'aujourd'hui qui fait
le plus cela et qui contrôle le flux de données
n'est déjà ni humaine ni coopérative,
c'est déjà une IA comme l'IA de youtube
contrôle le flux de données dans toutes les
sociétés sans doute plus que toute autre
entité et donc porter DCI est très
important et juste en faisant cela en
faisant un meilleur traitement de l'information, vous
avez d'énormes quantités d'opportunités et
dans de nombreux domaines différents, donc comme nous en avons
parlé  déjà sur la santé quand on parle
de problèmes mentaux, mais essentiellement toute la
santé concerne les informations que vous
voulez faire le diagnostic que vous voulez faire le traitement
et tout cela se résume à en savoir
plus sur les problèmes les raisons de
la maladie le diagnostic et ainsi de suite
bien l'éducation  est bien sûr trivialement une
introduction à l'information et parfois pas
si trivialement je veux dire une grande partie d'une bonne
éducation vous savez quand recommander
quel livre à quelle personne et c'est
très très difficile nous devons connaître le
processus de pensée de l'étudiant encore une fois
tout traitement de l'information est critique
et il y a d'autres applications mais je
n'entrerai pas trop dans les détails mais une grande partie
du problème de l'énergie concerne l'
information surtout si vous pensez
à voici le cas de l'énergie de fusion
par exemple où le contrôle du
plasma est  vraiment la puissance de traitement de l'information
et des articles récents sur l'apprentissage approfondi
à ce sujet et aussi si vous voulez faire le
bien en général dans les sociétés et aider les
gens que je  Vous avez bien besoin de savoir
quels sont leurs besoins et il y a un
grand contremaître à l'information concernant le
documentaire d'aujourd'hui sur Bill Gates discutant de
ce genre de problèmes qui sont fortement
recommandés, donc j'espère qu'à ce stade,
nous vous avons plus ou moins convaincu que
c'est devenu  urgent de faire un est comme le
système de recommandation YouTube inversement
bénéfique donc peut-être n'avons-nous pas
assez insisté sur le monde robuste ces derniers temps mais
vous ne voulez pas d'une solution qui ne
fonctionne que la moitié du temps et nous
allons parler plus de robustesse dans  dans la
suite car nous allons défendre la
deuxième série qui, malheureusement,
c'est aussi extrêmement difficile comme
s'assurer que ces domaines comme le
système de recommandation YouTube se comportent de
manière significative Rober c'est extrêmement difficile
c'est une recherche vraiment difficile
Harlan et ce n'est pas suffisant pour
demandez simplement à ces entreprises de faire le bien, vous
devez également créer de nouveaux outils pour
vous assurer que ces
[Musique]
par exemple
la vidéo
sur le précédent  vous pouvez imaginer
que cet algorithme d'apprentissage automatique
essaie de détecter la pédophilie à peut-être 99
% et ce n'est pas suffisant car
il y a toujours comme les gens qui
veulent télécharger une vidéo peuvent toujours trouver des lacunes dans
l'algorithme et le tromper en pensant
que  il n'y a pas de meilleure peur dans cette
vidéo donc
cette vidéo en grande partie maintenant vous pourriez penser
que vous pour éviter ce problème ce que
vous devriez faire est de faire un
apprentissage continu comme si vous appreniez juste un
algorithme et que vous le déployiez bien s'il
a un écart alors  tout le monde peut l'
exploiter et c'est mauvais, alors peut-être qu'en apprenant en continu,
vous pouvez éviter ce
département bien lorsque vous faites un apprentissage continu,
généralement, vous allez apprendre
des données qui vous sont
fournies et donc je ne sais pas si  vous avez
entendu parler de cette largeur de page, mais à Sarnia,
cela a essentiellement appris des données de
Twitter et je ne sais pas si vous savez mais
Twitter mais sur Twitter a donc c'est
le ouais donc il y a beaucoup d'autres
cha  nges vous voulez rendre solidement
bénéfique, il va en mentionner un de
plus, mais le livre beaucoup plus peut
-être le plus important est ce que
cela signifie d'être bénéfique, c'est très
très difficile maintenant, ce que les gens
font habituellement,
c'est que plus de philosophes aiment vérifier ces
anima très abstraite qui a été rendue
plus un peu moins abstraite par l'avènement
de la future subvention je suppose des
voitures autonomes donc c'est le problème du chariot
je suppose au point Roy pour les voitures autonomes
donc vous avez cette voiture et elle
ne pourra pas s'arrêter et  il doit choisir entre
tuer quatre personnes ou tuer ou des animaux de compagnie
mais l'une des personnes est un voleur
donc je ne sais pas comment la voiture le sait mais
et c'est donc le dilemme classique et
quand ce cas peut-être surtout mais dans beaucoup
cas, nous sommes fortement en désaccord et c'est un
problème, mais l'astuce ici était
qu'au lieu d'avoir cette approche,
les philosophes moraux nous disaient quoi faire
le MIT rapidement le site Web appelé une
machine Moore où ils demandent ces
di  des lemmes à différents utilisateurs bien dans un
utilisateur et ainsi ils ont collecté beaucoup de
données comme des millions de points de données de
personnes disant ce que je préfère cette
situation à cette situation et cela a
généré beaucoup de masse de gary différente
maintenant tout cela sonne bien mais si vous voulez
pour l'implémenter réellement dans une voiture, il
y a d'autres défis, par
exemple, vous pouvez demander quelle réponse vais-je
suivre, il y a des millions de
réponses que vais-je suivre maintenant
l'idée du groupe de personnes du MIT
et de l'Université Carnegie Mellon  est-ce qu'au
lieu d'écouter n'importe quel individu
pourquoi ne pas avoir un vote à ce sujet pour qu'ils soient
une église vous avez un vote sur les
différents utilisateurs d'un siècle les
préférences des différents utilisateurs mais
il y a d'autres problèmes qui concernent
le nombre d'imaginer plus de dilemmes le
nombre  des dilemmes auxquels la voiture peut être confrontée
est extrêmement énorme vous pouvez penser à toutes
les combinaisons possibles c'est un
nombre exponentiel donc c'est énorme
clairement nous n'avons pas les données  des points
comme les préférences de chaque individu à
propos de chaque dilemme possible, nous devons
donc faire une opération supplémentaire, nous devons
prendre ce que les gens ont dit et extrapoler
et imaginer ce qu'ils diraient probablement
avec quatre différents pour d'autres dilemmes
et un autre point est que les préférences des gens
ne sont pas nécessairement
cohérent comme il y a beaucoup de
recherches qui montrent que si vous posez
une question à quelqu'un, vous posez la question en
fonction de la façon dont vous posez la question,
sa réponse peut être différente, donc c'est
beaucoup de défis, mais essentiellement,
ce sont aussi des dommages intéressants comme la
voiture doit  faites toutes ces fonctions
en millisecondes parce que vous ne voulez pas
que la voiture fasse un choix en
millisecondes donc beaucoup de
changements techniques concernant la facilité maintenant
c'était pour le problème du chariot qui est un
joli poème mais c'est très abstrait et
poly non  ce poème percutant parce
qu'ils ne seront pas si nombreux à essayer des
dilemmes pour les voitures autonomes, mais
il y a un domaine qui est constamment f  face
à des dilemmes éthiques, vous y pensez
si vous y pensez, toute
recommandation de l'algorithme YouTube
est en fait un dilemme éthique,
alors imaginez par exemple un utilisateur qui
tape le mot Tramp sur YouTube et il
recherche Trump la première vidéo
qui va être  suggéré par le
système de recommandation va avoir une
énorme influence et est clairement en désaccord, nous ne sommes
clairement pas d'accord sur la
vidéo à promouvoir dans ce cas, bien sûr, j'ai
pris le cas de Trump, mais je pourrais prendre
n'importe quel sujet légèrement controversé et
il y aura  être un dilemme similaire
à YouTube et Facebook et tous ont eu
cet énorme problème de motivation du discours de haine
est cette vidéo devant cette
vidéo tombant dans le discours de haine c'est un gros
dilemme éthique et devrais-je le recommander
c'est un gros dilemme si je le
recommande l'utilisateur  va aimer ça il
va passer un bon moment mais cela
va aussi avoir des effets secondaires
comment répondre à tous ces dilemmes éthiques
sur des vidéos qui  n'ont pas encore été téléchargées
comme toutes les vidéos, de nombreuses vidéos
téléchargées sur YouTube à
chaque minute, il y a
500 vidéos téléchargées sur YouTube,
donc c'est très très difficile et ce qui le rend
encore plus difficile, c'est que nous cuisinons, nous allons
être en désaccord comme si c'était complètement
sans espoir, vous avez une délibération sur
toutes les recommandations possibles du
système de recommandation YouTube également parce que
comme la recommandation météo est
éthique ou non dépend de l'ensemble du
contexte, peut-être qu'une vidéo n'est pas
recommandée ce jour
-là parce qu'il y avait des événements à ce sujet  le même
jour ou peut-être pas à cet utilisateur particulier
parce qu'il a une sorte de bug sur c'est
une question très très compliquée et
ce qui la rend encore plus difficile, c'est que nous sommes
très mauvais avec Morpheus ou en général nous
avons plus d'intuitions qui sont pleines
d'erreurs  comme pour les biais cognitifs, si
nous posons la même question à quelqu'un de
différentes manières, nous obtenons des
réponses différentes si nous posons la même question à
quelqu'un si h  e est mangé ou pas il
va avoir des réponses différentes les gens
sont beaucoup plus sévères quand ils ont
faim alors comme par exemple
middie quand il a passé sa
soutenance privée de son doctorat il a donné des cookies
aux examinateurs parce qu'il connaît
ce respect donc il y a  beaucoup de
choses qui ne vont pas avec nos
intuitions morales et je pourrais aller beaucoup plus
loin comme nous aimons déjà
penser avoir ces idées nous avons
ces croyances souvent que nous avons cette
croyance que nous essayons de défendre même si
nous ne le faisons pas  t vraiment avoir une justification pour
cela comme il est très très difficile d'avoir un
bon plus et donc la proposition qui a
été faite par un gars appelé
Kazuki, âgé de plusieurs années, était qu'au lieu de
prendre nos préférences car ils espèrent que nous
ne devrions pas faire cela et à la place
considérez quelque chose appelé
particule de volition extrapolée cohérente le
mot important est poli donc intuitivement
la volition est ce que nous voudrions que vous
vouliez par opposition à ce que nous voulons
donc juste pour faire cette distinction  en clair
l'exemple que je prends toujours c'est le cas de
recommandation vidéo d'une vidéo de foot
et pour moi et il s'avère que j'aime le
foot donc quand on me propose ce
genre de vidéos j'aime j'ai envie de cliquer
dessus mais je sais aussi que  ça va me faire
perdre un peu de mon temps, je suis peut-être une
grande partie de mon temps accro à ça
et donc quand je vois cette vidéo surtout
s'il est tard dans la soirée ou quoi que ce soit que
je sais que j'aime, je veux cliquer dessus mais
Je voudrais ne pas vouloir cliquer dessus
donc et c'est fondamentalement l'idée comme dans de
nombreux cas, nous avons ces préférences
qui ne sont que des dépendances et nous voulons
ces choses mais nous voudrions ne pas
vouloir ces choses, je dirais qu'il est
devenu essentiel de faire  cette distinction
parce que programmer ce que nous voulons est
déjà ce qu'ils font tous ces
jours-ci si vous pensez à ce que fait YouTube
, c'est calculer ce que vous allez
aimer littéralement sur Facebook et il
s'avère que si vous ne faites que ce que les gens veulent,
vous avez  énorme effet secondaire  ts donc nous ne
devrions vraiment pas penser à faire
plus que cela, pas seulement ce que nous
voulons, mais peut-être quelque chose qui est plus
ce que nous voudrions et probablement
idéalement si nous étions plus intelligents si nous étions plus gentils
et mieux informés, les gens ont en
fait changé mon  attention s'ils sont
mieux informés sur des sujets importants
et cela devrait être pris en compte
peut-être à l'avance maintenant, tous ces éléments
combinés devraient conduire à la théorie de la conclusion
, donc si je peux, c'est vous que donc si
nous vous avons convaincu qu'il est urgent de
rendre aussi bénéfique et injecter et c'est
extrêmement dur de le faire alors alors le
corollaire naturel est qu'il est urgent de
mettre toutes sortes de talents dans les meilleures
conditions pour en faire un est bancal
bénéfique c'est nous vraiment le
message clé d'un livre comme nous n'  t nous
ne résolvons pas la forme de rendre soit
évidemment bénéfique
d'aider
dans un livre
toute conversation sur notre
si vous aimeriez aussi en termes de mise
dans les meilleures conditions signifie aussi
donner la part aux gens  cela les
intéresse et ce que je veux que vous fassiez pour le
Jamaïcain comme bénéfique et c'est vraiment
ce que nous essayons de faire dans le livre comme
nous essayons de présenter le programme stéréo
mais aussi comme des poèmes spécifiques qui peuvent être
abordés de manière indépendante  du
reste, alors j'espère que si vous lisez le livre,
vous pouvez trouver quelque chose qui est vraiment
intéressant pour vous et qui est également
utile maintenant que faire de cela, un
important est en fait d'en apprendre plus
comme c'est très comme jusqu'à présent, beaucoup de
gens ont essayé  parler tout le
temps de différents points de vue mais
ça n'a jamais été clair enseignez-moi comment
toutes ces idées s'emboîtent vraiment
de manière cohérente c'est vraiment ce
que nous essayons de faire dans le livre mais plus
généralement quelque chose que je pense que
plus de gens  devrait essayer de faire, il est
très facile de trouver de bonnes
idées, surtout si vous n'avez pas une
vue d'ensemble de vous et c'est pourquoi nous
vous recommandons vraiment d'en savoir plus et
s'avère qu'il y a un ne  w livre qui
est publié aujourd'hui pour le faire en trouver si
loin en anglais très bientôt maintenant vous
devez également vous engager et discuter je pense que
c'est très très important parce que ces
idées vous ne pouvez pas résoudre le prêt prêt dont vous avez
besoin de coordination et vous devez engager les
gens  aussi pour faire travailler les gens sur
cette émission et c'est très difficile à
faire car sur ces sujets il y a
plein de gens qui n'ont pas les meilleurs
moyens de débattre je dirais genre quand vient
les yeux il y a beaucoup de battage médiatique et sous
et critique  comme ce n'est pas très
bon de débattre et nous devons également nous
coordonner parce que ce sont tous des
défis qui sont très
interdisciplinaires et c'est en fait l'
une des choses que l'
altruisme efficace de l'organisation essaie de faire et
juste pour conclure, je pense que
j'espère que j'ai  vous avoir convaincu qu'il
est important d'en faire une croyance solide ici
c'est d'être parents
mais je tiens aussi à insister sur le fait
qu'ils sont fabuleux je n'ai jamais aimé
écrire ce livre j'ai vraiment vraiment
d  J'ai découvert beaucoup de choses qui sont
fascinantes, cela a vraiment remis en question ce que
je pensais croire et aussi c'était
vraiment passionnant et excitant comme c'est
vraiment vraiment certaines des questions les plus
intéressantes que je connaisse,
nous sommes sortis de la réflexion sur ce
genre de forums c'est vraiment  lié à
l'ISM bayésien également, donc il y a
vraiment beaucoup de fascinants et ce n'est pas ennuyeux
comme c'est ce que j'essaie de dire, c'est
un grand étang et c'est sans doute la plus grande
partie de l'humanité comme nous, je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus important et  beau et
fascinant que d'aller sur la lune par
exemple parce que parce qu'aller sur la
lune n'a pas fait grand-chose, cela n'a pas beaucoup
changé la conception du monde et notre
chemin n'était pas aussi difficile que nous pourrions le faire
avec le contrôle quelques années, certaines personnes
diraient ceci  est un premier beaucoup plus difficile,
beaucoup plus changeant et cela
va tout changer dans le monde, donc
c'est vraiment très excitant et j'espère que vous
pensez à trouver comment vous pouvez
contribuer à  ce projet
oui oui eh bien oui donc c'est très difficile
à calculer nous ne pouvons pas calculer tous les
effets secondaires et en fait à l'avance
c'est une période très difficile c'est indien
comme pouvez-vous appliquer la règle de Bayes si votre
vision et le premier signifient que le
premier Bayes  la règle n'est pas réalisable dans un
laps de temps raisonnable, il y
aura donc toujours de l'incertitude et vous
aimez simplement les données si claires que vous ne pouvez pas
imprimer tous les effets secondaires, mais vous pouvez
essayer d'estimer à quel point vous êtes sûr de
la possibilité de très mauvais effets secondaires
comme tout d'abord, je pense que vous devriez
penser de manière plus probabiliste,
ne vous donner aucune ambition, ce n'est pas surprenant que je
dis cela, mais je pense que c'est très important
et qu'il a été reconnu plus connu comme une
partie très importante des
ingrédients artificiels et si vous combinez comme un
plus  une réflexion probabiliste sur
les effets secondaires possibles et une estimation de
la gravité des effets secondaires comme
une sorte de fonction objective, alors vous
pouvez essayer d'éviter comme très mauvais  effets
secondaires
il y a la question ici dans le
flux YouTube, je vais demander à beaucoup de
gens de faire cette distinction claire
entre disons que nous nous soucions d'une IA forte,
ce n'est jamais clair pour moi ce qu'ils
entendent vraiment par cette vue mais je pense que c'est aussi
problématique  de le faire parce qu'il y a
ce sentiment que tant que ce n'est pas
fortement i ce n'est pas un problème et
dès que cela vient de l'IA, tout
change, une autre chose est ce mot plus grand
s'il y a un si grand changement comme
le GTA devient de plus en plus et  plus
influent et cela devient aussi de plus
en plus sophistiqué faire de plus en
plus de choses qui sont plus difficiles à faire les
soucis si vous y pensez se fait
automatiquement ce qui est de 500 heures de
vidéos par minute ce qui est et dans
ce laps de temps c'est aussi comme ça fait beaucoup  de
reconnaissance d'image détection de visage sur
les vidéos il fait du sous-titrage donc
traitement du langage naturel
traduction automatique des sous-titres et aussi il
apprend les profils de milliards
d'utilisation  rs comme étant donné ce que j'ai vu mon
historique sur YouTube, vous pouvez en déduire beaucoup
de choses, il a ce qu'on appelle une
représentation vectorielle de moi et une
représentation vectorielle de chaque vidéo c'est
déjà extrêmement sophistiqué ça
va devenir de plus en plus sophistiqué
ce n'est pas ça  étroit soit comme s'il
faisait toutes ces choses, donc bien sûr
ce sont des composants différents ou plus ou
moins le particulier qu'ils se connectent les
uns aux autres de la même manière que dans votre
cerveau, ce sont ces différents
composants du tout faisant ces différentes
choses que le  cortex visuel et tout
cela est étroitement lié et donc, comme
le meilleur génératif vient de faire de
plus en plus de choses et de faire en sorte que tous
ces composants soient plus connectés,
c'est déjà